when that trailer dropped dropped
every one before that when they started
again we're gonna talk about leaks
when they leaked that picture of uh
robert pattinson in the suit on the
motorcycle and it's just like some
production still
not even a production still looks like
somebody just picked up their iphone
took a picture and everyone was like
boo hit no twilight batman baby
i was like hey i just want to remind you
guys in 89
everybody went michael keaton yeah
beetlejuice kilmer like every single
batman
has been hated arguably val kilmer was
bad how dare you but valkyrie
i know bob kane said that he looks the
most like batman
of anyone they ever caused he was like
that dude looks like
he was like that dude looks like that
was towards the end of bob kane's life
in his defense he also looked at his
nurse and said the same thing
that's terrible michael keaton like
obviously like
did a great job but my one issue with
like 89 batman is that batman is just a
terrible detective like that's
absolutely just a love story
yeah 100 100 and but this the first time
they actually pulled vicki vale like
into
like the the mainstream the 89 batman
has one of my favorite little
random lines of when vicki vale comes
over to the
the mansion with uh dinner with bruce
wayne and
they're sitting at that giant long
dining table and and uh
she goes how often do you eat in here
and he goes truth is i don't know if
i've ever even been in this room before
i like that he's bad at being a
billionaire in that
movie he's like his batman is like
uncomfortable or his bruce is like
uncomfortable with being rich i really
like that about it but that's obviously
right
i i have predictions first of all
the second jeffrey wright came on screen
i was like
that may be the best even with gary
oldman might be the best choice for
gordon
i was like 100 he's got that world
weariness hasn't he jeffrey right he's
got that kind of yeah but just not only
that
but i'm sorry man no i'm not sorry i
love the fact that we are finally
starting to see these characters
outside of specific criteria
right the whole thing about batman is
anyone can be batman
it is greatness and greatness arising
from tragedy that has been
thrust upon you and
that's the same thing with gordon like
the whole thing with um
uh dark knight rises or or no not dark
knight
what's the what's the graphic novel what
am i drawing a blank turn oh uh
dark is that it's a gordon story
um and being able to understand that
he's not
this do good cop with the you know phone
under the glass that we saw in 66 like
he's a real man who's struggling ah it's
so good
but the prediction that i have and i may
i have not been watching react videos or
anything else
i think the body that you see in the
beginning is alfred
hmm because they cast my boy circus
haven't they and they cost you
the circus i think they caught you i
thought
they cast he's only i've directed him
he's in the volume
yeah that's actually very cool i think
andy circus i think they catch the voice
and you keep hearing the voice but you
never see him
and i think that alfred is the
disembodied ghostly voice of
his that is his um
companion spiritual companion for this
thing but the second that i saw robert
pattinson without
the cow i went they may have done it
they may have
finally cast young version like year one
i think he's year two specifically which
yeah same [ __ ] but
two is great yeah but it's it's like
early but it's like because there was
that one thing right yeah
he's looking a bit tired but like the
makeup is running a little it's not we
don't need to
yeah there may be a version of this
where
it looked like there was a version of
this where there um he didn't have the
cowl on he had like the old school
like i'm just gonna throw on a gym sock
over my face and go out and beat up bad
guys
um so there's a little bit of like
hybrid year one in there but
um the the fact that he looks like the
first bruce wayne
batman on camera yet
it's funny how i did not have that
reaction i i i love this this is why i
love this [ __ ] podcast
disagree with me baby well it was one of
those where i said
maybe i'm too indoctrinated to
the much later than year one or two
notion of
kind of coming into the batman story uh
but for me the note like i could see him
more easily in the role of batman than
in the role of bruce wayne
because it i you know not that i was
part of the like oh twilight la la la
crowd and i don't i never even saw
those films i don't have that baggage uh
to bring to the table in terms of like
him
but what what i see
i see you there i'm very much waiting to
see who wins this fight to decide what
fight i have after i
just actually empires and werewolves i
know i don't know how i feel yet so i'm
like fight it out
come on help me help me oh my god
i don't know there's a there is a
there's i think theoretically there's
supposed to be a certain amount of
gravitas to the bruce wayne
part that i for some reason just thought
i don't know that i feel it but here is
the thing
i i had that skepticism of
i mean part of it is that i'm just like
good god there's a lot of batman
just in general uh for like 17 years now
yeah
and yeah and so it's like yeah part of
me
part of me says you know i i just i
would give anything for
for something slightly more novel but
here was the thing
matt reeves is a [ __ ] great director
because i
i never would have predicted that when
planet of the apes was being
rebooted that it could be like
half as good and that that whole trilogy
to me is masterful
i i did not expect that they could find
a way to
completely rethink that franchise
because i think the first one is like
one of the
one of the great films you know and it's
obviously one of the great jerry
goldsmith scores so i got i got
okay i wasn't sure when you said the
first one are you talking about the
first reboot are you talking about
of course
i don't even think tim burton wants to
acknowledge contestant
yeah yeah no the original the actual
original film
uh is is just like a as a landmark film
and and the funny thing is there's like
five sequels and they get
crazy hokey and ridiculous and stupid um
but
um but uh but that first one to me
it's such a perfect of its era 60s like
cold
sci-fi where it's extremely sort of
expressionist and unforgiving
and so when they're announced a remake
and it's like james franco
you know and la la i thought okay and
then i saw it and was
[ __ ] speechless blown away that
moment the first time caesar speaks
is like one of those that you'll never
forget it was just an unforgettable
moment of cinema i did not expect those
movies to hit me
in the emotional way that they did at
all right that's just beautiful yeah
so good yeah no right to be it's amazing
but yeah so that's where i will see this
through because this guy has bought
an enormous amount of goodwill from me
where i'm like i i felt some skepticism
partly just burn out on batman but i was
like i won't see anything matt reeves
did you already have that skepticism or
did you develop that skepticism upon
seeing this trailer
i i don't i guess it was already there
uh
because i just laughed
yeah i mean i like i like nolan's films
for example quite a lot
to me like everybody else the dark
knight for me
is you know like that's one of those
where
it's just a transcendentally phenomenal
film but i actually am one of the people
that
am somewhat apologetic for uh dark
knight rises i think that films better
than most people give it credit for as
well
like cs lewis do you want to talk about
i have like
major issues with that movie that oh
dark knight
rises yeah i mean i think a lot of
people do for a lot of different reasons
right but the one thing that really gets
me from a storytelling perspective
is that they have bruce wayne
technically become batman
twice and i never understood why you why
you would ever watch that journey
twice why do they have him start off
needing to train to try to become batman
and then get captured by bane and need
to train again to become batman it would
have made so much more sense to me
if you're trying to get invested in
watching this character grow again to
try to protect the city and have all
those stakes
if he at the start when he was weak got
captured by bane
and then had the journey of becoming
batman i just think that it happens
when you do a batman movie you have to
either
reference dark knight returns or
that one panel where they swear bane
snaps his back so you have to do the
scene
if he was weak you can't do that scene
online you've not thought this through
my thing with this movie to me what they
the two things that they said
here is why you should here is how we're
doing a different batman story
because there's a lot of it that i was
like nolan nolan nolan
no i like i've seen these beats i've
seen this camera package
i've seen this lighting
except for the fact that the music is
the one we're like it's going to be
different
the choice of something in the way of
nirvana that
that album instantly takes me back to
like a
very like specific time in my life
because i remember when that album came
out
i was in high school it was just like uh
so
instantly a contextual re-contextualizes
everything for me
and then the second is the whole of
course the line
who are you supposed to be and the way
that he goes bam
bam bam bam and they pause and they're
like you've seen this before right
but what you haven't seen is this and he
ground and pounds that [ __ ]
i was like this is a different movie and
the the reaction on the guy's face were
like jesus he's
down dude and he beats as we would say
in texas beat the tar out that
you beat the tar out that boy i was like
this is gonna be a different kind of
batman movie so i was
i was like i'm i'm jeffrey wright
the music choice that scene bear in mind
that the trailer music choice has
very little to do with what to expect in
the film in the end
um i do believe that everything in that
trailer is meant to be
especially as a reveal trailer is meant
to be representative of
of the ethos at least of what they're
going
spiritually what they're trying to go
for with them austin do the 10 minutes
on why trailer music is different to
movie music that's a really interesting
topic
like genuinely the audience is going to
want that well i mean wait the headline
isn't written by the author
no i mean seriously that still blows my
mind by the way i was i'm still just
like
not always but a lot of the time i did
actually when i asked did any of you
know
why they call this a teaser
and not a trailer i feel like it is a
teaser
but why is it not a trailer when it's i
thought teasers were supposed to be like
15 seconds of
shots and no no like plot beats no
it's expectation management isn't it
because they've only shot i think i saw
the thing that they only
managed to shoot about 20 before before
lockdown so
i think it's expectation management it's
going we know it's like
three locations is that all they managed
yeah i thought they were further in no
20 which is crazy but i mean i
personally am um
i wasn't really excited about this movie
at all because i had not been excited
about
dc films more recently i feel like they
tried very hard to
uh just [ __ ] the bed yeah but i think
that the reason that they [ __ ] the bed
in a lot of cases was because they were
trying to immediately
jump into the world ending scale that
marvel was at
rather than taking their time and
spending the 10 years on trying to build
up to that they were like
end of the world let's do it every time
which is just this biggest thing the
stakes are way too high
especially when it's the same film where
i'm learning who this character is
you don't have to meet aquaman you're
like god yes
just chill out a bit slow down for a
second i think also give it a second i
think the fact that the films are
generally
like that this is where shazam was such
an incredibly bizarre and interesting
left turn
austin your internet's breaking up
there's so many that's pretty good
they're so humorous right now those
movies are so
they're so dour and humorless that i was
like
that you know there's a fun factor to
the mcu
that to me means that like it's the
classic thing of it can disarm you
to actually it's being like wow i
actually care about iron man
or you know captain america or thor
or ant-man i care about them more than i
expected because i've
i didn't think i was investing because i
was mostly laughing and just kind of
popcorn
enjoying and meanwhile dc is like frame
one the fate of the universe is at stake
and i am glowy
and my my you know my parents didn't
love me
and like it's like you know they kind of
locked themselves into that like in the
80s right with dc like dc historically
is very
um like ever since basically since dark
knight blew up and basically like
started a new generation of the comic
book industry
sorry not dark knight sorry returns the
[ __ ] comic
in the 80s like they definitely have
lent into the dow and this
watchman as well uh all by all the alan
moore stuff so like the
vendetta all that like that there was a
vibe that was set although was that
vertigo i can't remember
um vertigo i thought viva vendetta was
vendetta's vertigo you're absolutely
right yeah anyway but but i feel i feel
like the whole like dc
machine became we are serious comics i
remember when i was a teenager
like marvel was like the silly fun stuff
but if you were like
grown up you read dc because that was
broody and melancholy and all that stuff
i think that's possibly they got even
darker more recently
i feel that's i think that's but i think
that's i think they kind of pushed
themselves down that channel and it
meant that when the movie stuff happened
you either have to get christopher nolan
to make like art movies basically that
have the characters in
or you end up in kind of the zack snyder
verse stuff where
it feels very kind of it's working very
hard to convince you it's for grown-ups
while actually also
still having to sell action figures um
sorry v for vendetta was dc
but i was pretty sure that it was under
it was the under the vertigo label but
it was still dc
oh it's vertical sorry yeah this is
where i show my ignorance vertigo as a
sub
a sub label yeah but i mean it's also
kind of like you know
marvel nights and stuff like that but i
thought vertigo
was more fringe at that point but that
was still maybe yeah i feel like they
they went in comics and boom yeah
vertigo and stuff have
always always been a little bit i've
always been a marvel boy except for
except for batman
but there's some there's some fringe um
graphic novels that
if you want to break away from like
mainstream superhero stuff
some great irredeemable we're gonna
throw it out again read it
i preordered i pre-ordered the trade of
that when we brought it up in the show
last time
i'm looking forward to reading that the
um and the other thing speaking about
the mainstream
sorry speaking about breaking away from
the mainstream a lot of people are about
to wake up on robert pattinson which is
great because he is genuinely of great
that's been a very interesting one
that's why i think that they showed him
beating the [ __ ] out of someone
in that trailer is because yeah a lot of
people are
did have the reaction of like how how
dare you cast
twilight sparkle boy as uh batman but a
not that i have any issue with twilight
i've not seen all those films but i
don't think it's
inherently garbage for whatever reason
uh
he hates them more than anyone else he
[ __ ] hates those movies and he's so
vocal about it he's been very outspoken
about yes
i don't think that they they expected
that they were making this like cute
little like
book spin-off indie thing that then just
like
blew up uh they're gonna make harry
potter for tweens
well i don't think they expected the
popularity though is the impression that
i get
really yeah that's what what he was told
at least and then it just blew up like
crazy
oh from his perspective i thought from
the studios person i was like it's 100
but they are they're very small they
kind of do weird stuff like hunger games
was similar john wick was similar like
that's their that's their vibe is they
they take long bets
and yeah a lot of them have paid off
recently which is cool for them but
so then he did twilight and then sort of
just went off and did
a lot of more artsy films um i mean did
you guys see the lighthouse most
recently
was i've not yet i've not been able to
emotionally bring myself to watch it
given where i'm at
i don't think you'll struggle with that
movie emotionally in any way
oh really where we are now lighthouse
came out two
lights a year ago yeah no it was very
recent was it
i don't think honestly guys i have not
been watching movies i just haven't been
they haven't
really captured my i mean
i'm the kind of person at the moment
yeah anytime anyone would ever ask me if
i want to go see a movie i say yes it
doesn't matter what the movie is i will
always be like absolutely let's go see a
movie and because
they're not coming out i like going to
the movies
yeah i like going to the movies but i
would much rather
like like austin and i were talking
about this i'm going back
back through boardwalk empire right now
just because
i would much rather something about the
serialization
and the character development that's
that the writing that is that is
afforded
in something that is more long-form than
even like a two-hour movie it's just
way more did we did we talk about um i i
feel like we did
forgive me if this is re-treading but
did we talk about dark
on netflix the german show i think you
might have mentioned it
none of you have watched it though right
it's three seasons
it's built to be three seasons it's it's
not one of those let's see how it goes
because once you get into it you realize
this could never possibly have been
open-ended there's no way they didn't
write all three seasons before
shooting the first episode i just can't
fathom it because
the 4d chess of this game
this show is unbelievable as a time
travel
uh premise like their their
conceptualization of everything and just
the the thinking three moves ahead at
all times i'm three episodes from the
end of season three and i'm just like
the intellectual sort of strain it's
like going to the gym
uh this show that that uh in the most
interesting way but you have to you you
cannot half
watch it uh i mean it's one of those
that there's no scenes ever that are
thrown away
and so sold me on the whole it knew
where it was going thing i'm so bored of
showing well any time anyone could
please around we'll get confused yeah
anytime anyone tells me uh this is a
specific small amount of season and
and it has been written that way i'm
like yes let's do it
luther to me was the same weight where
it's like all right four episodes
sherlock same thing it's like four
episodes this season we're done we're
like
all right as opposed to which one
luther or um although both of those went
on a little bit long towards the end
there some of those later seasons of
sherlock and luther yeah
and i i think cumberbatch and uh um
oh but oh my god huh idris elbow
no martin oh
speaking of can we just say what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah
dude i i think it's beautiful it is it
is
sad absolutely but i mean like like
david bowie
like just to go good night everybody i
had not heard a
peep about him having cancer and and the
level of
i mean but dignity and stoicism and
beauty that that show
and strength of character that that
shows from him is
so [ __ ] remarkable i mean it's look
overwhelmingly
sad that he died is my first takeaway
cancer research is still just not
getting enough funding and it sucks
because like i recently did a
stream for pancreatic cancer which has
eight percent survival rate and also
which is the least of any kind of cancer
and also the least funding and i feel
like
like based on walking with that
foundation uh pink one
the public reception at cancer seems to
be that people have decided that it is
uncurable and thus
they don't get a lot of money in
donations for research
it's like we publicly have decided that
it can never be cured so let's not try
to cure it like across the board it's
it's really bad um so it's like just oh
never really thought about it but you're
right that is how i think about cancer
actually you know you say
yeah it's i mean for whatever
interesting intellectual flaw in my
makeup that's interesting cancer
cancer is what got my dad and when he
knew
he had you know this was inescapable
he read this book about it that has the
most perfect title
um it's called the emperor of all
maladies
and um and it and it and the book made
very clear
that i i have it i haven't um i haven't
read it but he
he my dad voracious reader and
intellectual through to the end was
was incredibly fascinated by even the
thing that he knew was killing him
and so he um
like was explaining that we think of it
as
we just need to pour more money into the
research or we or we need to just do
more testing or more experimentation or
what
but the thing is the cancer is like a
family
of problems more than a single issue
and it's one of those that it's just
it's just kind of like a defect in our
code as it were
that it how you can't you can't treat it
like a bacteria or virus where there's a
specific thing
that you have to develop an attack for
it's it's your own body malfunctioning
in such a way that
you know it's one of those that it it's
really hard to imagine it ever being
cured
um not that i am remotely cure is
certainly not the right word but i think
um having uh
more reliably like efficient treatments
developed is is the
goal well certainly yeah my diagnosis is
for
surgery as well i think six surgeries
this year to get rid of his cancer and
it'd be like we'd wait two weeks and
he'd have to go back to the doctor and
be like
is it gone maybe like grew back again
because it was growing so fast that
every time he would get it cut out it
would just come straight back and then
obviously chemotherapy ended up
happening too but
it just it was the image was the
approach to that treatment was it like
we're going to try this or was it more
this is going to stop was it more
definitive or was it more speculative
going in
two for those surgeries for my dad's
surgeries
um i
i mean because i can imagine the
emotional roller coaster was like this
is going to cure it or fix it at least
and then or or a bait
and it's like the the like like you said
you wait two weeks i wasn't sure if
going in
if science is is at the level of
arrogance to say
this is going to do it no medical
professional is going to say that to us
that's
going to be absolutely hedged yeah
that's what's asking what your specific
experience was so
i never spoke to the doctors obviously
my dad being in australia so i never was
able to go on any of those visits with
him or anything but
uh he never seemed to think that any of
them would be
definite and the doctors were always
like let's hope this one works let's
hope this works
so it seemed like they were pretty
reasonable about about it every time but
uh back to chad bozeman i think one
thing that was very obvious to me is
because i remember having a conversation
with someone about this maybe six months
ago he just looked really thin
and people were being so rude to him and
i was like he's sick he's obviously sick
with something
but was flooded with comments of why do
you look so thin why are you so thin
look how gaunt you look and i was like
please like let this be a reminder to
everyone who made comments like that
about how he looked too skinny
that you don't know what's happening in
people's lives when you say awful things
about them
please i hope you remember leaving those
comments because we never talk about it
when men's bodies are concerned either
because obviously men still get cold too
fat or too thin
just as much as women with maybe a
little bit less poison where hollywood
is concerned but it's still a huge thing
it's like just remember how hurtful that
especially if you're famous for being
like a superhero yeah yeah
but that's what i'm saying like to his
credit again the fact that there was no
rebuttal
the fact that there was no i'm going to
appeal to public empathy i'm going to
respond to that or make people feel bad
for saying comments like that
i i wasn't aware that people were making
comments like that again
i i remember when david bowie dropped
black star
my initial i was like i've got to listen
to it the david bowie record listen to
us like
wow maybe you should have just kind of
left it with golden years like you
didn't need to put out this album
and then i realized what it was it was
his he wrote his own eulogy
and he contextualized his own experience
and the second that i remember the first
time i listened to it i listened to it
in my car
the second time i listened to it i was
on a train
in the uk and just this the the sheer
difference of environment and headspace
that i was in listening to is like
this is one of the most brilliant things
that david bowie has ever done ziggy
from the
ziggy starters and the spider from mars
pales in comparison to black star
for the fact that he never said anything
and just went good night everybody
is just i hope that i have that level of
character and strength and resolve
if when my time comes no matter what the
cause is
i hope that i can meet it with the power
and strength and confidence
that david bowie and chadwick boseman
did because that's just
right next i respect the take but i also
want to say that i think that
people who are very open about dealing
with the struggles that they're going
through can benefit people
massively and i don't think that they
are necessarily weak
for publicly talking about it i don't
think troy is implying that the opposite
is
bad no i i i
or yeah it's not an either or thing it's
that
talking about it and to me coming out
and going hey um
who was it that just recently um
began talking about his he had a
terminal illness i can't remember who it
was
but being able to own it on its face and
go like like austin's dad is like i'm
fascinated with this thing
i want to learn about this and it became
his favorite subject it was one of those
it was it was like you couldn't you
couldn't not talk about it because there
were
it still represented a frontier of
knowledge you know yeah
or people that that go out and be decide
to become champions for this and say
listen
i have the resources or the platform to
be able to speak to this
and i'm not talking about going into a
cave and dying privately
i'm talking about being able to say i
will look at this thing in its face and
understand
that we go hand in hand together into
this dark serious thing
but i refuse to be dragged into it by it
and that to me is it's it's not about
you know being being silent and and but
there is a level of stoicism that says
this is happening to me well yeah not
letting it define him the fact that
the the fact that when they said that he
started treatment in 2016
and i was like he [ __ ] shot civil war
and
black panther and infinity war and
end game and there's this movie that
just they just recently did called 21
bridges and
a host of others i was like and you know
those especially a movie like black
panther
you know that is a physically insanely
demanding role there's all these fight
scenes and all these
you know wire like i mean i know
obviously there's stunt doubles for some
of that [ __ ] but there's a lot
that's got to be him and i'm like and
just the amount of physical
uh endurance um i was just
speechless that was the thing that's a
real life superhero yeah it's crazy
that's the real life superhero mike
you're being incredibly quiet
i'm yeah i'm i'm hearing everything you
guys are saying and and
i respect it massively i i think there's
a risk with romanticizing any one
approach to something as massive as
death
yeah generally i agree and yeah i think
i think
i think i mean don't get me wrong those
are this is a great way of handling it
and the bowie things great way of
handling it but
i also think kind of kicking and
screaming and tearing the world down
around you as you go is absolutely
equally
yeah i think if you have cancer that's
how i'm yelling about it i still respect
that's how it intend to go i will i will
i'll i won't
i will not go quietly into that night um
but yeah i think i think i i know that's
not what anyone's saying i think that's
kind of what maybe alana was saying as
well is that
there is a risk whenever you romanticize
or say say what the an approach it has
shows strength or heroism
there's a risk potentially of kind of
diminishing or dismissing kind of
the other approaches which you know if
he'd become a great advocate for it that
would have also been
an awesome strong position to take if he
honestly kept it entirely private
basically i think i don't think there's
anything kind of wonderful about
death unfortunately there are ways of
meeting it which i agree with you
there's there's poetry and
and niceness in it but at the end of the
day it's a it's a tragic thing that a 43
year old man
you know has passed on so yeah but
basically i was quiet because i wasn't
like disagree with
anything you were saying i just didn't
think i had anything useful to this is
such a great conversation
and i i because it is the
death is the great period
it is it is the great absolutely is the
great equalizer
i just there there's been a lot and i am
i am steeped in this right now because i
mean 44 right so i look at chadwick
boson anybody who is
before me i go holy crap or
especially right around my age i go oh
my god
and i have austin is one of my closest
friends
and the fact that he lost his father
travis willingham one of my closest
friends he lost his father
and now i have a son and so i go
oof what does it look like for traveler
if i'm no longer in the picture
and i said something to pam yesterday
and i said i'm going to be
out of his life longer than i will be in
it
ideally sad i yeah ideally
hopefully yeah that's how it's supposed
to be nothing
gives me anxiety makes me sick to the
pit of my stomach like thinking about
losing my parents
and you saying that just made me go oh
[ __ ] like
i hate it so much here's what i can say
to you as as in this situation as the
child
right and i'm speaking to it as a father
that's how i think of our relationship
[Music]
[Laughter]
there is there is something there is
sadness and death
yes i'm not and i i'm not diminishing
that at all
i i've been reading so much about this
because i was
paralyzed by fear of death paralyzed i'm
i'm not
over catastrophizing my vernacular i
literally it would shut me down
and i wouldn't i would either not be
able to sleep
or i would not be able to think because
i was so crippled
by the fear of this and i've had to get
to the point
because i'm not at all scared of dying
i'm scared of my parents dying
sure um for me
i think a lot of it has to do with
coming to terms with how i was raised
and what
death meant and it was the ultimate
judgment
um i i think that there's
i don't know a lot of that's a it's a
amazing question for me to unpack is
why did it mean so much to me and not
only that but why was i doing
stupid things to my body like smoking a
pack and a half of cigarettes a day
in order to exacerbate and deal with the
anxiety of that right
yeah it's the most counter-intuitive
yeah but like a lot of it
i i i started reading um
marcus aurelius and and the notion of
like here's a dude that struggled with
this healthy
his entirety of his life he watched all
of his kids except for one and his wife
die
and he was like this thing will either
break me or i will learn from it and i
will meet it as a friend
and his last words were if you now grant
me leave to go
then i will bid you farewell and pass on
ahead of you
and to me that is just like that is i i
to be to not only be at peace with it
but also to be able to
offer peace to those who will be
grieving to me is just a wonderful
tremendous gift
i never slept better the night that i
signed a a life insurance policy
um for travelers like i can go to sleep
now because i've
taken care of my family and specifically
my son
and i think it's just for me i have been
like like austin's dad
i've been fascinated and fixated um
on death for a while and i think that
watch this
like bruce wayne there is the ability
beautiful there it is we are the pearls
on the necklace
the pearls of wisdom on the necklace
to be able to say this moment may define
me
but it will not define me in tragedy it
will define me and triumph
i will use this as fuel to become the
best version of myself
as opposed to remaining the worst
version are you i can relate to that
massively like that's definitely kind of
because my family sorry go ahead
i can't yeah so we just moved it away
instead of dropping it
it's good no it's but it's true and i i
can relate my men in my family
have kind of died relatively young so
i've always had this kind of assumption
that i wouldn't
you know have a long life and that's
definitely kind of driven me to do
awesome stuff
uh and try and yeah maximize it min max
my game
i think i'm a little bit similar to that
but also my i have no obsession with
death because uh i've been sort of sick
my whole life
so so like my parents made me sign a
will last year my mom was like you keep
fainting
we don't know like there was one day
where i i fainted and i hit my head and
i passed out and i didn't remember
anything that had happened for several
days beforehand
so like they were like look if something
happens
we just don't want everything that you
own to get stuck in the u.s and that was
like a serious reality that i had to
deal with it
parents eyeing your cyberpunk chair i
did write and i
i find this so funny but i recognize
that many people might find this like
evil and absurd
um i specified in my will that my mom
has to publicly display
the death stranding baby uh collectible
that i have
yes i was like i give that to my mother
she must display it openly somewhere in
her house
[Music]
did you feel better after you wrote your
will i've been scared though because i
think that i've always been someone
who's sick like you know like i had my
first serious asthma attack when i was
like eight and i was in hospital so it's
like i think that that's that's the
perspective i have and also speaking to
like
if you speak about you know uh chadwick
boseman
going quietly um i only spoke up about
my health issues at the start of last
year because there was a period where i
hadn't
made any public content for like four
months and people like what is this and
i was like let me just actually openly
talk about it
um for the first time ever even though i
had been sick for a lot longer than that
and i feel like more than anything it
helped people because i've had so many
people reach out to me now i've had
similar
issues sure about it so
it's it is of course i've gotten
criticism where people have like called
me a hypochondriac despite
the thousands of dollars they've put in
the medical system they do that anyway
they're like
sure uh i was like there's like [ __ ]
so much money last year but
uh and then there's also people who'll
be like oh you just talk about being
sick all the time
um which you know so people like do
definitely treat you like you should
shut up about it but ultimately i felt
like it was a helpful thing for me to do
and speaking to people was was helpful
and then i have a lot of people reach
out to me who also have cfs which is
like a very difficult thing to deal with
um that that's even been helpful for me
to have other people to talk to about it
because i don't know anyone else who has
it so
yeah i think speaking up about those
things can ultimately be tremendously
helpful but it does mean that i've never
had any fear of death
i have fear of losing my parents before
me i'm
always like i'll probably faint on a
staircase and that'll be it
and i'll be like peace we did it did my
best but
because of that i'm not worried about it
which is like i think very nice but it's
very foreign to me the idea that
like people would be worried about death
though naturally you should be right
well it's funny because it makes sense
there's a logic to it
there's a logic to it yeah the thing
that i think we overlook is that death
is
always only bad for the
everyone who cares about the person that
died it's it's it's the least
problematic for the person who actually
does die yeah
well said solves all your problems and
um
you know that that the the with the
caveat of
how you die um is you know
may make for a horrendous but but most
likely short experience
um but but again it depends on what
we're talking about and i don't want to
go down that road but the to your point
alana specifically
i shared that feeling for a long time i
remember
my i was my dad they were very close you
know like with this
this uh dawn treader and there's a
million stories like that
we did a lot of projects together a lot
of you know
you know home kind of projects you know
let's remodel the basement blah blah
blah he was always mr handyman mr
renaissance man in general um we did a
lot of those things and but the thing
he was also a surgeon so i never went to
like a doctor i would just always ask
him
uh uh and um
and so there were a million times
growing up where if i had a question
about something
the answer was always here's the answer
or
let's go look it up together and
i remember distinctly at like maybe age
12
13 maybe before that
one day i just out of nowhere i don't
think it was spurred by anything
but i had this sudden realization of
he is not going to be around forever and
i felt this sudden
vulnerability because i thought i go to
him for
so many things that i don't know how to
like function
without this source of knowledge
support everything camaraderie whatever
you want to name
just love and compassion it felt like
holy [ __ ] i've built a weakness
into my system where it's like you know
if you if you
if if life takes a shot at this specific
element of my life it will do
disproportionate damage
to other aspects of of my life versus if
it had taken a shot at other parts of my
life
and and i i had this
fear of how can i possibly it wasn't
it wasn't it was it was equal parts
emotional
vulnerability but also literal pragmatic
like i don't know how to life
uh i depend uh on
my parents and my dad in particular for
questions and i remember through into my
20s it's like the first time i'm
filing taxes on my own and it's like all
right
what the hell is this form and it's like
he always seemed to know the answer to
everything
and i know i romanticize it but it just
feels like that
my memory repaves over the details to
make it
just that he was the one stop shop for
everything dad does sound ravenclaw
as [ __ ] it was all i mean and he uh
but the funny thing was
that was never ever ever that everything
i'm describing is antithetical to
everything that he
believed in as a father his whole thing
he because he was you know eagle scout
growing up and all that
his mentality was i want to teach you
to depend on yourself and all those
things were actually his way of kind of
preparing for that and then i remember
when i was literally sitting by
his bed knowing that he had days at most
left
it dawned on me all of this suddenly hit
me
and the last words literally i ever said
to him were i want you to know
that i'll be fine without you and
he smiled and was basically he could
barely speak but it was like
you just made me tear up i have tears in
my eyes because that's i i don't mean to
i know that this is a
this is a vulnerable spot for you and
i'm not trying to pry anything open i
promise
well that's i just want you to know that
i went through a similar arc and
my parents are healing is is the thing
the difference is that they're [ __ ]
useless my mom's like what's a pdf and
i'm like
uh so we don't have the relationships
they can't
carve boats no no boat carving in your
family my dad my neighbor
that was the most perfect that was
literally the most
perfect response i will never talk
i will never top that down no there's no
part of me that is like depends on them
or calls them for questions it's that
they call me
great austin my parents are useless
are they are they eating okay i don't
know what they're gonna do we can just
worry about them all the time
but it certainly i i do have that
anxiety of like i can't imagine
what i would do if either of them died
and obviously that's going to happen but
it's like a crippling fear of like
oh [ __ ] that i just like have to subside
that some movies i just like have
trouble watching i think it was
guardians of the galaxy 2
like just very much deals with the theme
of a parent dying and so the whole time
watching that movie i was like
oh god it's just really dude also every
disney movie like it's a joseph campbell
thing it's like just ah
if you want empathy instant orphan
that's how you do it
you know everybody i i saw a friend
share a list of
the the 20-odd pixar films ranked
um and two
related to this topic two things come
out
from that is that one they said which i
generally agree with
that up is actually not one of the best
pixar films
it has one of the best vignettes that
all of cinema
has produced town i was also in the
theater going jesus christ yeah like the
fact that that and that's obviously
apropos what we're talking about like
that film
took you through the the sort of journey
of death
in a very five minutes beautiful perfect
fast track twice emotionally yeah but
similarly uh everyone i think would
agree
every sane person would agree that toy
story 3 has to be one of the absolute
highlights of
all of pixels and your internet's
breaking out
wasn't it and he's right with uh with
the conveyor belt right with the
recycling
so here is the thing here's the thing
that there's the reason why
especially with regard to how to how to
kind of approach
throughout your life like pixar are
going to kill buzz lightyear
like you genuinely believe in it you
know what you know why i think that that
that moment is one of them i love it
that moment as one of the most
kind of beautiful explorations of death
is that what i love is that they're
heading towards the fire
on the conveyor belt and their response
is to hold each other's hands
and to just face it they don't they stop
struggling
and they're like we're in it we're in
this moment and i was like all right
like what that movie to me is perfect
the whole toy story franchise to me is
perfect but
one of the toy stories was the highest
rated movie ever
on rotten tomatoes until
um i believe lady bird
temporarily knocked it off that's what
so there are loads of movies that have a
hundred
like if i look at the list citizen kane
has a hundred godfather has a hundred
rear window has a hundred
uh casablanca has a hundred but rear
window has a hundred yeah
it does what it does well i don't even
think hitchcock would have said that
so you know um fine yeah but i believe
that in terms of like
the volume of reviews right
weighted weighted it's just everyone
reviewed it because it was toy story
right
uh i'm not sure if it was three or two i
think it was three yeah i think you're
right and then ladybug
temporarily beat it and then one guy
gave it like a less
a lesser review and it knocked back down
or something like that if i remember
just to be a dick
yeah toy story movies it's such a guy
thing i don't think i don't know
there's a um there's a really um there's
a really
cool book i read a few years ago called
death set to music which is about
seminal classical pieces um that explore
this and one of the most famous
is mahler9 and there's an incredible
documentary uh of leonard bernstein
talking
about dear do it bethel
[Laughter]
oh my god i'll pass it we're moving into
like david copperfield land right now
bethel pulls out that book austin is
this your copy
yes exactly
exactly he's uh he's uh
um magician magic the yeah i was trying
to think of what's the
david blaine he's turning all of us into
blanetologists
you don't believe me watch but this um
this go find on youtube leonard
bernstein
talking about mahler's ninth symphony
because the amazing thing is that you
think of a traditional classical like
19th century beethoven blah blah
symphony
they very often end you know where they
get bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and it's all about the you know
and mahler9 does the exact opposite
where first off the piece is gigantic
it's an hour and a half long you know an
average beethoven symphony is half that
and so this thing you know i remember
buying it as a kid on cd and it's two
discs of
the one piece and so the final movement
is like
it takes like 30 minutes for the thing
to end and it just keeps getting smaller
and it is to me it's one of the most
it's one of the most uh perfect
representations through the abstraction
of some art form of
of that process because it gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and
quieter and quieter and quieter and then
you think it's done
and then it has this little last gasp
and it tries to build up and then it
gets smaller and smaller again
and then it tries to build up but it
can't get quite as high as it did the
first time
and he takes his time and there's this
just unbelievably beautiful
uh thing of bernstein describing it and
it was one of those that
it made me think and i can put the
question to you guys so that we
we mention games at least once today um
has has any game ever done that is there
again i can't think i found myself
sitting here wondering
is there a game that has ever explored
the actual
act of death in a way
like that like a piece of music you
would think it's like
you don't think but i can't think of
something that i mean that dragon cancer
yeah
i was gonna say that dragon cancer is
probably like the most like but that's
not
that's not that's about observing death
not about someone who's dying
right not experiencing dude uh austin we
have a separate call to get on
after this call i actually thought of
something by the way too that we do need
to discuss
i um well i will i will submit i'll come
back to your questions
yeah i'll submit to you this the way
that i viewed death in my 20s and my 30s
and now in my 40s
um has been an absolute progression and
there's a picture that pam took
of her grandparents um she went out back
home to alabama and
was just taking these beautiful shots
that she has of her grandfather
and every time that i get annoyed
whenever pam is like
can you pose for this picture and can
you i was like let's just be in this
moment not have to feel like we're
you know posing for it i'm surrounded in
our heart
in our house by the art that she creates
and and it's the only
it's the only like like tangible
photographs are the only
analog ways that we can you can pass
down
um memories like everything else is like
hopefully apple's around in 40 years
where we can look at videos that we've
stored on the cloud we have no idea
but she has this picture of her
grandfather and her grandmother
standing at the burial plots that
they've reserved
and it's as if they're shown as like
here's our garden there's our tomatoes
they're going good and uh here's where
we're gonna be buried and
uh yeah we feel pretty good about that
and they just have this
almost not not even dispassionate but
kind of like non-showers
yeah that's where we're gonna be and i
was like i
think that's that's maybe that's that's
the
the goal is is to be able to to get
there
but not have it take 96 years 85 years
75 years or 45 years
but to be able to get there as quickly
as possible
so that the best gift that we can give
the people who are
left is going is exactly what austin
says like i know i want you to know i'm
going to be okay
that is not a that's a result of
austin's character but it's also a
result of everything that his dad did
to to build into that so that's that's
that's kind of who i want to be i just
want
the people around me to know that i'm
okay and that
they're going to be okay that's the gift
that i want so then no you can't think
of a video game
i can't think and to be clear
if anything awful happens to me i'm
really angry about it
no matter what i like it
you know one of my life is preferred but
death is okay
one of my uh no what remains does that
make you sort of count i mean that's not
oh that's an interesting thing it's
definitely about dealing with death
my one of my favorite quotes i i i'm a
big fan
he was not perfect but i'm a big big fan
of troy and when he was dying he said
something very memorable
uh he just didn't know it at the time
yeah that's the only thing about death
that i'm afraid of now is saying
something stupid i remember he
he just put the pink and blue lights up
and he was
he talked a little bit about death and
then from like unfortunately
i cannot wait to see the comments i saw
i saw a meme once that said
um i saw a meme once that was that was
like i'm sure my death will be caused by
being sarcastic at an inappropriate
moment and i thought
that's going to be on my tombstone for
sure
but now one of my favorites like the
royal tenenbaums though what's the royal
tenenbaums one
that mr turnbound died rescuing children
from an orphanage yeah
that's the that's the that's the
gravestone that's that's yeah it's like
there was a burning bus full of nuns
yeah yeah yeah i did what i could and
puppies
my some reason there was a unicorn there
and it was the only one ever
one of my one of my favorite public
speakers irrespective of one's thoughts
on his politics or his philosophy one of
my favorite
orators of truly all time was christians
but hitler's too obvious you got to go
for someone say star wars
someone say hitler and someone say jason
shout out
that future t-shirt where it's just like
on the back it's a word cloud
well no i was thinking is that the
cities on the tour it's just all the
different things that we have
to like and the dates that we said
they're on oh sorry go ahead austin
so no well it's short the so hitchens uh
had cancer uh and that's what killed him
and but he remained a very public figure
through till the very very end and he
just refused to back down
and uh there was a an event once where
he did a public kind of debate about
religion
with he and sam harris um and
um a uh
one of them was a famous jewish rabbi
whose name i'm i'm forgetting
um and uh and then a fourth guy and
i've not heard this stroke so there was
a rabbi an atheist i know exactly
it's a perfect setup
i wish i wish i could live up to the
setup you've just given me but uh
so yeah good one go ahead they do this
like
they do this like two hour discussion
about religion and politics and blah
blah blah
mostly on religion and blah but um
hitchens is bald uh through this and he
had never been bald but he's obviously
undergoing cancer treatment
and so they end the night of the you
know spirited debate
uh where the moderator says you know all
right you know
all of that said uh just one last
question
for you all here but for mr hitchens
um how are you feeling and he says well
i'm dying
but so are you hmm and i was like
in one sentence uh it it's just sums it
all up you know we don't
we don't choose the time thank you
yeah it was great it was it was
something comforting in it that that's
that's that's the reality there's this
corollary adjacent to star wars
one of them uh star trek
uh uh my wheelhouse a great moment
from a movie that i think is also given
a short shrift unfairly is
the first uh tng movie generations
um i've always known it together
everyone always everyone always shits
all over that movie and i never
understood it's better every time you
watch it uh generations it really does
i i i thought that the also the the
chance to see
the two captains play off each other's
sensibilities was
is is quite delightful three minutes
right like for three years that's
as long as you could get those egos
together in the same way
but what i love is that malcolm gladwell
get him out get him out get him out get
up
his whole thing is he's called malcolm
mcdowell it's mcdonald's
malcolm glad gladwell's the author yeah
malcolm oh you were actually i thought
you were i thought you were changing
i was doing a joke with a guy actually
he said malcolm
in the canteen wow he's trying to he's
trying to move the sun near the planet
to kind of prove
no he wants some he wants to escape
death oh yeah yeah malcolm gladwell is
doing yes he was proving blink
through his uh his massive genocide yeah
um yeah mcdowell malcolm mcdowell's
whole thing of trying to escape death
where he says
time is a predator that stalks you and
what i love is at that final scene
where they're on spoiler they're on the
wreckage of the enterprise
recovering what they can and he finds
the photo album picard finds the photo
album of his
childhood in the chateau in paris and
all of that and
and uh there and um and uh
he and he and riker are talking and he
says you know someone told me once that
predat time is like a predator that
stalks you but i think of it as a
companion on the journey to remind you
to save her every moment
and it was always always like what a
perfect picard kind of
moment too um it's just yeah
just perfect it's also a really nice
secular approach to the same
conversation which is which is very star
trek to do
to do that kind of philosophy but in a
very secular way which uh which
is cool yeah absolutely poetic too on
the non-religious end of things as well
yes i don't think you need heaven to
comfort you about death nor do i think
you need hell to make you fear death
i think that's something done out of
just the the point has no moral value
thank you completely agree that is that
that to me is everything is like
and the flip flop on its own it's it's
the flip also things done
for for reward
yeah exactly someone did present it one
way and said um hell is not a
hell is not a punish or hell is not a
punishment in heaven is not a reward
they are both simply god granting you
the truest desires of your heart on an
eternal level i was like
it's an interesting notion but i don't
think you need
either of those things to help you deal
with death i think that you
death is enough on its own and i think
what you need more than anything is just
conversations like that for me
i believe that that eternal the eternal
uh part of it though for me is very
existentially terrifying the idea of
like your punishment
or reward or even neither it's some kind
of
neutral purgatory the idea of the
status quo is now how far are you in the
game
i have not i have not yet i've gotten
many tweets
ever since we've brought that up though
for people asking oh my god austin it's
going to be your favorite show
what should i watch mike bithell i let
you down i i
am myself i should have said watch the
good place right now
get to that final season and that is
just like oh
man all right all right oh man we need
to yeah
because to me here's the here's the
analogy here's the analogy analogy that
i would draw with regard to my
profession
i think that music
is only made meaningful by the silence
before and after
and that's partly why on every game for
example i'm always saying
do we actually need a cue here because
it would be probably more interesting
the music doesn't come in for 20 minutes
that's that's always your thing isn't it
it's uh
director's like i'm like austin it's got
to have a theme shoot he's like no 20
minutes
absolutely well no it's i mean i
remember when bioshock
i'm with you though it's percussion it's
tempo right yeah it is
it you you want you want to feel the
purpose in it and to me that is that is
a metaphor
to life like if you know mark i think it
was mark twain who said
something i'm paraphrasing because i
don't remember the quote exactly but he
said essentially that he doesn't if
he doesn't fear his non-existence and
death because his non-existence for the
billions of years prior to his life
didn't bother him much either and uh
i i to me that's a pretty good take like
you know
we it's hard for us to imagine not
existing because it's all that we've
known
uh but there's the overwhelming majority
of time we didn't
uh and we can we can sort of understand
that and so for me the idea that
we didn't exist for it you know 13 plus
billion years um uh multiverse
not withstanding the potential potential
of that calculator only on this show
would you have to take a side bar
of course we're not talking about
quantum mechanics like talking about
string theory
or the maltese let's presume a euclidean
universe
uh going well come on guys i just
listened to the latest episode
clearly he would be the one yeah well
you know no i find
that we would get the aliens guy we
would get the ancient aliens guys
true i find our irrelevance comforting
and i always have like
i'm very small and insignificant um in
the grand scheme of things
and i find that really comforting it's
the same as like some people look at
videos of the planets you know you can
see like a human and then it zooms out
and it zooms out then it zooms out i'm
like
just shared one i love that more of that
real blue dots
great um yeah what episode number is
this
this is episode 27
27 but i also did just want to like
before we wrap up right now
um i actually think it's like you know
kind of nice that
uh in in any small way chadwick
boseman's passing
led us to having a beautiful
conversation about death
um that's legacy yeah but obviously a
hell of a lot of respect
to him and i think that i'll probably
leave a link in the description to where
you can i think my my campaign
for uh pancreatic cancer obviously
different to colon cancer which
uh unfortunately he suffered from um but
the campaign's still up so you can
donate so i'll just ask anyone who's
watching to do that
help people who have cancer it would be
wonderful i think anything that can draw
attention to that
is is a worthy endeavor so thank you for
being a part of that
thank you for facilitating these
conversations too and austin thank you
for bringing it up
we were going to talk about robert
pattinson for the entire thing who i'm
really excited about and also like i
think it's really cool that we're going
back to a more damaged younger batman
agreed
yes i was going to say my closing
thoughts on the batman after having just
discussed death very profoundly
uh that i'm very excited i think paul
dano is a fantastic actor like so
good that i find it distracting i'm like
[ __ ] how is he so good at acting
uh that cost is incredible colin farrell
not looking like colin farrell is such
an interesting choice because he's so
he's not calling this
dad who there was have they confirmed
yeah because so is it prosthetics or did
he just put on a bunch away it's
prosthetics
he's so handsome why are you not cars an
ugly man like i don't
i'm speaking as an ugly man i feel like
you're not an ugly man you're beautiful
you need only read the comment
mikey that's why i said the comments
that's what i said soak it in soak it in
enjoy yeah this is why i live
if i was dead i wouldn't be able to
enjoy these kind exactly my favorite
colin farrell movie
um is probably uh in bruges
he's very good in that he's very good
and if you ever go to bruges it is
really want to go there yeah um
also zoe kravitz absolutely love her so
this is a really great cost uh it looks
really dark which i love like as a
batman fan
um and it seems like it's taking vibes
from the long halloween so just to
anyone who made it this far and is still
caring about batman uh as your resident
batman lover
i'm gonna tell you read the long
halloween it's great and it i think
that's what this movie is going for so
hopefully calendar man makes an
appearance
and he's everyone's favorite but we'll
see it's the
favorite fringe we haven't done we
haven't done a clay face
we have we could do a clay face in there
that'd be kind of
that's kind of what long halloween is
yeah but calendar man is one and and
and then suicide squad having poked out
man is very funny to me
uh as a man that looks really fun that
suicide squad movie
i think suicide squad is going to be we
haven't talked about any of this we've
not even talked about all the
the games the rock steady stuff and the
games i know dc
knights which is a great logo is a good
logo i'm concerned that the game is
going to be
very games of service micro transactiony
but unclear right now but that is the
impression i get
and troy's giving a facial gesture that
implies that he agrees with that
presumption
i'm worried about it i'm worried about
it um but
yeah we can get into that next episode
yeah on play
watch listen yeah sorry we didn't even
intro the show wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
before we do that before we do that
before we do that that's true
there's something else we wanted to do
thank you so much for watching play
watch listen i'm alana uh i'm joined by
troy austin and mike what are we talking
about today mike
we today are going to be playing a
special song
aren't we austin and troy oh my god
thank you very much for the reminder
there you go austin takes away
happy birthday all right this is one for
you a lot of piss
take it take it to the top there appear
maestro
take it yeah right there we go take it
from the top there
that's again happy birthday
happy birthday to you thank you
happy birthday
[Music]
drunk on the power that comes with
having a podcast
that's right everybody beautiful work